productivity dysmorphia is the inability
to see one's own success to acknowledge
the volume of your own output it sits at
the intersection of burnout impostor
syndrome and anxiety it is Ambitions
Alter Ego the pursuit of productivity
Spurs us to do more while robbing us of
the ability to savor any success that we
might encounter along the way I've
started thinking of this unhealthy
relationship I have with my professional
achievements as productivity dismorphia
and I said I have realized that it is an
inability to see my own success it's
like I'm looking in the mirror of my
professional life and I don't see the
published author staring back at me all
I see is a failure productivity
dysmorphia is just this total jaded
opinion of what we do of the
achievements that we have made of the
outcomes that we are getting on a
minutely or daily basis especially if
you're a work from home kind of person
or work for yourself because who you're
comparing yourself to there is
definitely a case to be made that you
should see your level of productivity
with a lot more equinity than you do